the Pentagon may get more involved in
Afghanistan after more than 15 years of
fighting their President Trump will
consider a plan to add more troops to
the fight against the Taliban the plan
would increase the number of American
and NATO forces in the country Margaret
Brennan is at the White House with
what's next in the fight against the
insurgents Margaret good morning good
morning well recommendations from the
president's top national security
advisors will land on his desk
this week and it puts in front of
President Trump a key decision of
whether to expand the US military role
in Afghanistan already America's longest
war mr. Trump will be advised to deploy
around 3,000 more troops some American
and some from NATO allied countries to
join the more than 8,000 US troops
already assisting the Afghan military
the u.s. is requesting that NATO
contribute as many troops as possible
and then the number of American troops
would depend on that NATO contribution
but a high-ranking military official
tells CBS News that the Pentagon will
ultimately decide on the number made
available President Trump will also
consider lifting Obama era restrictions
on the targeting of Taliban militants
which would effectively pause the so far
unsuccessful US efforts to broker peace
talks the aim here is to leverage
battlefield gains against a resurgent
Taliban in order to force them to the
negotiating table with the us-backed
Afghan government now May 25th is the
working deadline for President Trump to
make a decision that is when he meets in
Brussels with NATO allies Norah all
right Margaret thank you so much